SALADS HERSELF.
WORTH REASSESSMENT, I GREEN.
TUCKER THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO
HANNITY AND TONIGHT THE CONSTANT
ASSAULT ON YOUR FREEDOM FROM THE
SELF-SERVING POLITICIANS IN THE
WASHINGTON, DC SWAMP IS
UNYIELDING WITH THE HELP OF A
FEW WEAK KNEED REPUBLICANS A
BRAND NEW GUN CONTROL BILL JUST
ADVANCED ON CAPITOL HILL.
IT WILL DO NOTHING FOR GUN
SAFETY IN SCHOOLS.
WE'LL EXPLAIN.
SENATOR CRUZ, HE OPPOSES THIS
LEGISLATION, WILL BE HERE TO
RESPOND.
THAT'S COMING UP.
ALSO, WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR
PLAN TO BAN JUUL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AND TAKE NICOTINE OUT
OF CIGARETTES.
ALL WHILE YOUR GOVERNMENT IS
LEGALIZING WEED AND, IN OTHER
PLACES, HARD DRUGS.
THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
GOVERNMENT MAKES A FORTUNE ON
TAXING TOBACCO, OVER $12 BILLION
A YEAR.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO GIVE THAT
UP?
ANY WAY WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
BIDEN'S WAR ON YOUR ABILITY TO
LIVE YOUR LIFE WITHOUT GOING
BANKRUPT.
NOW, BETWEEN INFLATION, SPIKING
GAS PRICES, RECORD PRICES, A
LOOMING RECESSION, AMERICANS ARE
SUFFERING AND IT'S ABOUT TO GET
A WHOLE LOT WORSE.
ACCORDING TO ONE WASHINGTON POST
COLUMNIST AND ON MSDNC, YOU ALL
NEED TO STOP COMPLAINING AND BE
GRATEFUL THAT JOE BIDEN IS YOUR
PRESIDENT.
RIGHT.
>> JUST GOING TO SAY THIS AND IF
I GET BANGED FOR IT I DON'T
CARE.
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
AMERICANS WHERE IT IS
UNCOMFORTABLE THAT THEY'RE
SPENDING MORE BUT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO GO UNDER.
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOT TO STOP
COMPLAINING WHEN THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO LITERALLY, THE
INFLATION RATE MEANS THEY MAY
ONLY HAVE TWO MEALS INSTEAD OF
THREE.
SO I'M GOING TO NEED YOU TO CALM
DOWN AND BACK OFF BECAUSE IT
FEEDS KNEE THIS FEAR AND THEN
THIS FEAR FEEDS INTO PEOPLE
MAKING DECISIONS THAT CREATES
THE VERY THING THAT THEY'RE
FEARFUL OF.
AND IF YOU'RE IN THAT CATEGORY,
CALM DOWN.
STOP LOOKING AT YOUR PORTFOLIO.
>> Sean: CALM DOWN, BACK OFF,
STOP LOOKING ALTHOUGH YOUR
PORTFOLIO, EVEN THOUGH
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS ARE NOW
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK
BECAUSE OF BIDEN ECONOMIC AND
ENERGY POLICIES.
THAT BUILD BACK BETTER TURNED
INTO SETTLE FOR LESS AND SHUT
YOUR MOUTH PRETTY QUICKLY.
LA TIMES MEANWHILE HAS A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT TAKE.
LOOK AT THE HEADLINE.
QUOTE, YES, A RECESSION LOOKS
INEVITABLE BUT IT MAY NOT BE A
THAT BAD.
HMM.
OKAY.
THE ARTICLE GOES ON TO EXPLAIN
THAT IT WAS JUST A NORMAL PART
OF AMERICAN ECONOMIC LIFE.
NO, IT'S NOT N REALITY, THIS
LOOMING RECESSION, COUPLED WITH
MASSIVE INFLATION, COUPLED WITH
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES, THIS IS
A DISASTER THAT IS IMPACTING
ESPECIALLY THE POOR, THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND PEOPLE ON FIXED
INCOMES.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THIS SINCE, OH,
THE JIMMY CARTER YEARS.
BUT DON'T WORRY BECAUSE BIDEN
JUST INTRODUCED HIS BIG NEW
PLAN.
HE'S GOING TO SAVE EVERYONE,
$0.18 ON EVERY GALLON OF
GASOLINE YOU BUY, A BRAND NEW
TEMPORARY, GOD FORBID FOREVER
CANCELLED GAS TAX HOLIDAY THEY
CALL IT.
AND ACCORDING TO JOE HE'S DOING
EVERYTHING HUMANLY POSSIBLE,
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE, WITHIN HIS
POWER, TO BRING PRICES DOWN.
HE IS TRYING REAL HARD.
>> I PROMISE YOU I'M DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE, EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE, TO BRING THE PRICE OF
ENERGY DOWN, GAS PRICES DOWN.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ALL
WORK ON THIS TOGETHER.
>> Sean: EVERYTHING HUMANLY
POSSIBLE, EXCEPT CREATE MORE
SUPPLY WITH DRILLING PERMITS.
EXCEPT RESTARTING THE KEYSTONE
XL PIPELINE.
WE WOULD BE GETTING 900,000
BARRELS OF CANADIAN OIL A DAY IF
WE FINISHED IT.
EXCEPT LIFTING THE BAN IN
EXPLORATION IN ANWAR OTHER
FEDERAL LAWS.
EXCEPT GETTING REFINERIES BACK
ON LINE.
COME TO THINK OF IT, BIDEN HAS
ALREADY DONE EVERYTHING HUMANLY
POSSIBLE TO DRIVE UP THE PRICE
AT THE PUMP, DRIVE UP INFLATION,
ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THE WORLD'S
SUPPLY OF THE LIFE BLOOD OF THE
WORLD'S ECONOMY, THAT'S OIL AND
GAS, JUST LIKE HE TOLD US HE
WOULD DO OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
HE'S DOING EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID
HE WOULD DO WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
IN 2020.
I'LL REMIND YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF WE DON'T STOP USING FOSSIL
FUELS --
>> WE'RE ALL DEAD, SUBSIDIES FOR
FOSSIL FUELS, NUMBER TWO,
HOLDING THEM LIBEL FOR WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE PARTICULARLY IN THOSE
CASES IN THE UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND YOU KNOW THE
DEAL, OKAY.
AND BY THE WAY WHEN THEY DON'T
WANT TO DELIVER, PUT THEM IN
JAIL.
>> KID 0, I WANT YOU TO JUST
TAKE A LOOK, OKAY?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE.
BUT I WANT YOU TO LOOK IN MY
EYES.
I GUARANTEE YOU, I GUARANTEE
YOU, WE'RE GOING TO END FOSSIL
FUEL AND I AM NOT GOING TO
COOPERATE WITH THEM, OKAY?
>> WOULD THERE BE ANY PLACE FOR
FOSSIL FUELS, INCLUDING COAL AND
FRACKING IN A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> NO.
WE WOULD WORK IT OUT.
WE WOULD MAKE SURE IT'S
ELIMINATED.
>> Sean: ELIMINATED.
WE WOULD WORK IT OUT.
YOU GET THE DEAL.
FOR GOD SAKES I'M DOING WHAT I
SAID I'D DO.  AS FOR THE GAS TAX
HOLIDAY ALMOST EVERYBODY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY INCLUDING
BARACK OBAMA AND EVEN NANCY
PELOSI ALREADY REFERRED TO THIS
AS A POLITICAL GIMMICK WHICH IT
IS.
I'LL TAKE THE $20 OVER THE
SUMMER THAT IT WILL SAVE ME BUT
IT DOES NOTHING TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND WE'RE ARGUING OVER A
GIMMICK TO SAVE YOU HALF A TANK
OF GAS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE ENTIRE
SUMMER, SO THAT EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON CAN PAT THEMSELVES ON
THE BAT AND SAY THAT THEY DID
SOMETHING.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THINKING
ABOUT IMPLEMENTING THE FEDERAL
GAS TAX HOLIDAY.
I MEAN, THAT TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDS THE 18.THREE CENT PER
GALLON TAX ON GAS.
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
HELP OR IS IT MORE OF A STUNT?
>> LOOK, I MEAN, I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTING TO BE
SEEN DOING SOMETHING, BUT IT IS
PRETTY MUCH A STUNT.
>> I'M NO FAN OF THE GAS TAX
HOLIDAY.
I THINK THAT'S KIND OF A GIMMICK
AND EVENTUALLY YOU HAVE TO
REVERSE IT.
>> IT'S VERY SHOW BIZ, OKAY?
LET'S JUST DO SOMETHING.
THERE IT IS.
BUT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY LANDING
IN THE POCKET OF THE CONSUMER.
IT'S TAKEN OUT OF THE TRUST
FUND.
WE HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT, TO
RETURN IT.
>> Sean: KAMALA'S SECOND --
SHE'S ANYWHERES LINE IF ANYTHING
GOD FORBID EVER HAPPENED TO JOE
AND THAT ONE'S SECOND.
EVEN OFFICIALS IN BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S CAN'T GET ON
THE SAME PAGE WITH THIS GAS TAX
HOLIDAY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS MONTAGE PUT
TOGETHER BY TOWN HALL.COM.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO LAWMAKERS
WHO ARE ALREADY CALLING THIS
FEDERAL GAS TAX HOLIDAY A
GIMMICK, SAYING BEST CASE
SCENARIO IT WILL SAVE DRIVERS
ABOUT 20 BUCKS A MONTH.
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT THIS IS A
MODEST -- IF WERE JUST THE
FEDERAL GAS TAX, $0.18, YOU
KNOW, IS A MODEST, YOU KNOW,
MODEST AMOUNT.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, $0.18 PER GALLON, WHICH IS
GOING TO GO A LONG WAY IF YOU
LOOK AT THE AVERAGE OF STATES,
THAT'S $0.30.
JUST LOOKING AT THOSE TWO
THINGS, THAT'S ALMOST $0.50.
THAT'S GOING TO GO A LONG WAY
FOR THREE MONTHS.
>> IT'S GOING TO GO A LONG WAY.
THAT'S THE SAME PERSON THAT
ACTUALLY SAID, IT WAS VERY WINDY
THE DAY JOE TRIPPED THREE TIMES
GOING UP THE STEPS TO AIR FORCE
ONE AND THE SAME PERSON THAT
SAID I HAVE A HARD TIME KEEPING
UP WITH JOE.
WOW, HERE'S THE TRUTH.
IF YOU DRIVE A SMALL TO MID SIZE
SUV, SEVERAL THOUSAND MILES THIS
SUMMER, YOUR GAS SAVINGS FROM
THIS GIMMICK WOULD BE AROUND 20
BUCKS.
I'LL TAKE THE 20 BUCKS, NOT
EXACTLY LIFE-CHANGING, THOUGH.
AND I GUESS IT'S SLIGHTLY BETTER
THAN BIDEN'S LAST PLAN OF ACTION
WHICH WAS TO DO ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING AND BLAME TRUMP AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND FOX NEWS AND
OIL COMPANIES.
IN FACT, THE ADMINISTRATION,
THEY HAVE BLAMED PUTIN FOR
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING.
INFLATION, GAS PRICES, WE'VE
SHOWN YOU THE CHARTS YOU KNOW
IT'S A LIE.
ACCORDING TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
PUTIN HAS A MUCH GREATER
INFLUENCE OVER THE ECONOMY THAN
JOE BIDEN YOUR PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE THAT IS ALL NONSENSE.
SIMPLY IT'S A FLAT-OUT LIE AND
TODAY FED CHAIRMAN JEROME POWELL
COMPLETELY OBLITERATED BIDEN'S
FAVORITE TALKING POINT.
TAKE A LOOFRJTS GIVEN HOW
INFLATION HAS ESCALATED OVER THE
PAST 18 MONTHS, WOULD YOU SAY
THAT THE WAR IN UKRAINE IS THE
PRIMARY DRIVER OF INFLATION IN
AMERICA?
>> NO, INFLATION WAS HIGH
BEFORE, CERTAINLY BEFORE THE WAR
IN UKRAINE BROKE OUT.
>> I'M GLAD TO HEAR YOU SAY
THAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SEEMS
TO BE INTENT ON DEFLECTING BLAME
AS RECENTLY AS THIS PAST SUNDAY
SPREAD THE MISINFORMATION SAYING
PUTIN'S INVASION OF UKRAINE IS
THE BIGGEST DRIVER OF INFLATION.
I'M GLAD YOU AGREE WITH ME
THAT'S NOT THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: RECORD 8.6% THE HIGHEST
IN 40 YEARS CPI AND ONLY 1.4%
SINCE VLADIMIR INVADED UKRAINE
SO IT WASN'T VLADIMIR THAT'S
CAUSED AMERICA'S INFLATION.
YOU LIKE HIS ENERGY POLICIES,
THAT WASN'T CAUSED BY PUTIN
EITHER.
HIGH GAS PRICES, PUTIN DIDN'T
PUMP $2 TRILLION INTO AN ALREADY
HOT U.S. ECONOMY.
JOE BIDEN D PUTIN DIDN'T
ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE AMERICA'S
PRODUCTION OF OIL AND GAS, JOE
BIDEN DID.
PUTIN DIDN'T LET SOCIOLOGY
MAJORS STOP PAYING THEIR
GRADUATE DEGREE LOANS, JOE
BIDEN, THAT WAS HIS GIFT WITH
OUR MUSTN'T FRANKLY I'M SICK AND
TIRED, I'M SURE ARE YOU, TOO, OF
JOE BIDEN REFUSING TO EVER TAKE
ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANYTHING
HE DOES BUT WHAT SHOULD WE
EXPECT FROM OUR LONG-TIME LYING,
CORRUPT AND DISHONEST PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, THE GUY WHO USED HIS
CRACK A DICTIONED SON TO MAKE A
BUCK AND LIED ABOUT HAVING ANY
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS, WHO LET HIS
SON PAY HIS BILLS, A GUY THAT'S
BEEN LYING AND CHEATING AND
PLAINLYIN
PLAGIARIZING HIS WAY THROUGH
LIFE.
THE GUY WHO SPENDS HALF THE WEEK
ON VACATION IN DELAWARE.
TONIGHT DESPITE ALL OF THIS
THERE MUST BE ONE PERSON THAT'S
HAPPY.
SOMEWHERE IN AMERICA, JIMMY
CARTER WHEREVER YOU ARE,
PROBABLY SMILING.
THANKS TO JOE, HE IS NO